hello David you are the UK's premium
warhammer fan yeah so fed saying tam
usually says nerd but fan ah yes I'm a
bit nicer about this fancy you know he
goes for the hard sell on that so you
went to play this latest game Warhammer
ke or Spain yeah which is ostensibly
sort of like Diablo Diablo but Warhammer
Fantasy yeah so talk us through the sort
of setup how was it you know what was
your impressions of it it's it's very
tight to the fantasy law but at the same
time it's doing a really good job of
just appealing for people who want and
another action game to play at another
Diablo like to you know smash enemies
and chase Lou it doesn't really need a
background in Warhammer to enjoy but if
you're a Warhammer fan especially when
I'm a fantasy fan I think you're really
going to dig it fair enough yeah I mean
I played a bit of Diablo 3 when that
came out on switch and obviously that's
a really that's the benchmark that
people hold these higher games to like
so so what sort of similarities does it
have to that sort of core diablo
experience experience well there's that
the classes themselves it's got four
classes soldier which is like the tank
character the high off mage the dwarfs
layer which is the DDPs that we'll see
later in the video and the wood elf way
watcher which we haven't seen yet but if
you know what i mean if you know these
games you can deduce by what I just said
and you know it's gonna use a Bernero
obviously yeah if you know Warhammer
then you you know a bit more about it
but I don't want to say stock Fantasy
characters but yeah I mean that's it's
it's that's like what action RPGs like
this need right they need yeah a tank a
DPS a mage and a ranger that's that's
usually what it does but there's a lot
of flavor added to them as well you can
see me moving this shield around one
thing I really like what chaos Bane is
doing is that the right analog stick has
a function for every class so for the
the mage he can move all of his spells
round that's nice was that the fireball
that yeah about manually so you can see
me moving the
- combined with buff that the soldiers
using to get the best of both worlds
when I shoot a fireball you can move the
fireball so basically just circle
enemies you have loads of different
abilities that you can you know like I
said move independently of your
character
the soldiers right thumbstick ability is
his a shield bash you see him using that
every now and again the dwarf Slayers
ability it's basically like a reverse
scorpion where you throw a chain acts at
someone instead of come over here you
just go to them and just get right into
the melee it's so satisfying when it
happens nice like let's talk about sort
of how accessible it might be then first
say someone on myself who doesn't really
know
Warhammer like what kind of experience
would that like with that a person like
that get out of this game you're going
to enjoy if you're someone who enjoys
going into games like this and smashing
loads of enemies hoarding loot making
your character look cool using daffle
abilities over-the-top spells all that
sort of stuff it's going to appeal to
anyone who likes that kind of experience
those hack and flat flash I'm not gonna
tell you you're wrong but for what I saw
there was tons of abilities you have
these godlike abilities as well that you
can start leveling up when you give
favor with your chosen guard which is
what the soldiers doing they're dealing
out some serious damage there yeah
that's like the the comment of Sigma or
something it's it's that's that's the
the the line that I feel these Warhammer
games need to tread they need to appeal
law wise and flavor-wise
yeah Warhammer fan but they need to be
accessible so what you saw is like
madman and armor running in with
comments flying about you dots that on
the base level that's enjoyable
yeah I'm sold on just the mad carnage
that's happening here yeah but if you're
a Warhammer family uh yeah Sigma I know
who that is yeah I know where the war is
the Empire I know who this high off is I
was really just right there just in
nerdlings follow me again this is my
godlike ability you just summon like a
dragon head that pops and you again you
can move that around with the right
thumbstick that was that was one of the
most interesting wrinkles the game for
me because it everything that I was
doing it felt engaging yeah and I could
fire one fireball and get the most out
of it but I just
keeping it inside an enemy or I can just
spam loads if I need to get out of
trouble it's it's if it means that each
attack that utilize that utilizes that
wrinkle has you know yeah I like her
purse to it I like how they've got
ricochet effects there that was quite
fun
yeah bouncing fireballs yeah obviously
they're made of and is that can you just
spam that or is that sort of like is
that gotta cool down on it it's got as
you can see in the bottom right that the
golden meter similar to you know other
games like this you have to generate
your your manner or your rage if you're
if you're a soldier so it's not
something you can spam you have that
lightning ability which is kind of your
default attack for a soldier it's just
you know a strike and then those attacks
will build up the meter to use your
special attacks so it's not like you can
all your all your big fun attacks yeah
great they're a lot of fun they'd look
flashy but they're not gonna be
something you can just just spam but you
can build your character any way you
want if you want to just have passive
abilities and just like make yourself
super buffed buffed the team that you're
with make your basic attack really
strong you can get by um passives or you
can ditch all the passives and just have
loads of really cool abilities that you
can use whenever you want they were they
were very clear that you can just build
the type of fighter that you want like
like I said if you want to just spam
like a attacks
knock yourself out you can make your a
attacks as powerful as you want so how
does the sort of the questing work is it
very similar to how Diablo sort of so
you've got like the central hub areas
and then you should have venture out
into dungeons and all that sort of stuff
it does have a hub area from what I saw
it was the city of known again doesn't
mean anything to you yeah I'll take your
word for it if you're not a fan just
know it's a cool fantasy city what have
a fans be like
are we talking more Rivendell are we
talking more like Gondor there we go
it's just gross and dank and dark rats
living underground Laketown then like
there's all these demons in your sewers
it's like I'm crossing I'm crossing bit
like sea mythology here it's a bit like
Birmingham dig Wow but from what I saw
at the levels our procedure generated
there's a
main story in the background but you can
revisit dungeons this was a kind of a
pocket dungeon that I had that was
pre-built but when I played as the dwarf
Slayer it was all preceded generated so
they didn't know what the level was
going to look like what enemies I was
going to find what boss I was going to
get at the end of it what what blue I
was going to get yeah
again these kind of games they need to
have that replayability wrinkle right
that's how Diablo lasts so long that's
how a lot of these games live and die
they need to be satisfying to play again
and again and again and having that
procedure procedural generation I think
is a solid backbone for that because you
know you can take to these dungeons
again and again and again fight some
Nergal fight since the Nash fights some
core somewhat these like before so
there's four chaos gods and they make
the enemies in the game so now go yeah
basically no glove stinky boys or
plague-ridden and zombified corn mad
barbarians and berserkers and they
worship a blood God so an ash worshiper
got a player a player a god of pleasure
so they're a bit you know was seductive
and slender and snake-like
and zien she works the worships the god
of knowledge so they mad spellcasters
and mutating into Birds
butan that's the great thing you don't
need to you don't need to care about
that to play that game
but if you saw all the characters they
described you it's accessible right you
put it on the screen you're seeing what
looked like zombies and small little
demons if that's if that's what you need
to know that's all you need to know yeah
I mean they are mostly numbers so the
end of the day that's what you care
about this is a numbers game you want it
I for one when I play these games I want
to see the numbers but yes I find it
really satisfying to be like 4000 damage
6000 damage eight hundred damage kick
you can however alter the HUD and the
gameplay experience to whatever you want
so if you want no numbers you just want
to see the enemies the health bars you
can do that yeah so it's a little dwarf
ladder this is the the dwarf Slayer yeah
my favorite thing you'll see me pick up
in the world dwarf Slayers in the law
they the business they're trying to die
so they want to fight bigger and bigger
and bigger and being on bigger things
which makes them a perfect dps character
but because he they want to die they
don't wear Armour but in a game like
this you need an arm of value to make
the game satisfying to play yeah so his
armor is from his tattoos and bid what's
yeah you can get stronger beards which
gives you better armor okay that's it
what this definitely seems like a game
for you Dave like oh yeah with bears and
tattoos and and more hammer it's like
it's my perfect niche there's like a
sort of a Venn diagram all the things
that I am have culminated into one video
game this is perfect well I can make you
play as well because it's got um it's
got four player co-op yes I was gonna
ask alright how does that work so
obviously that Diablo sort of hooks
around like that multiplayer angle being
able to close friends which is great and
so can you get that sort of same
experience yeah here it's it's like
super satisfying to drop in and drop out
you'll see another elf join me shortly
we can drop in your your your play is
not interrupted by anything that your
your your co-op partner does in some
games if your co-op partner wants to
fiddle with a menu you're like oh you're
makin sit in the menu as long as he
wants it doesn't doesn't pause the game
instance yeah I guess it all drop in
drop out it's not cross-platform but
what's really nice is that you and I can
play is the tattoos and beers that found
ya you and I can play split screen or
shared screen on one someone else can be
playing on the internet on a different
Playstation yeah same for PC and Xbox I
did ask about switch not ready to talk
about that but fingers crossed because
it has to come to switch a game like
this is it is a perfect fit so yeah like
I said fingers crossed we we will see
something like that because I mean I
want my commutes to work for me to be
collecting dwarven beards and axes and
tattoos and making my lad
see how cool like school be Emma it's
it's it was just I played it for about
an hour and a half yeah and you know
people when we when we make these
comparisons due to the a below it's it's
so I always feel like it's meant as a
compliment because that is you know like
I said that's a benchmark that's
something for games like this to aim aim
towards and it gave me all the
satisfaction that those games did I of
course I'm going to
be a little bit more biased because it's
existing in a genre and a universe that
I personally hold quite dear he's a huge
Warhammer fan but I'm also very critical
of games that use Warhammer as their
storytelling device because it's so dear
to me so to have this game that was a
super satisfying to play and I be I feel
like it's being very faithful to you
know put of the local franchise and the
law is greatly even got Mike Lee who is
black library author himself like a
Warhammer writing alumnus like someone
who actually knows his stuff to come
help you know produce and write the the
game story so I mean just off the back
of that you know it's faithful to if
you're a Warhammer fence could be
faithful to the hobby that you hold dear
it's always good to have that sort of
authenticity and yeah sure and the
authority of someone that actually
writes for whatever subject to source
masseur you were working with so I think
that would definitely give it sort of an
extra layer yeah and if you just want
you know what seemed for the two hours I
play just a really fun action hack and
slash Diablo like cool you've got that
you got buttons to mash and enemies to
crush and skills to level up and loot to
collect I don't know else you want mace
that's all you can ask for really sounds
good to me does it have Zelda in it
that's all I care about
no not every game has held aren't you
big nerd it's cuz Diablo 3 got Ganondorf
armor can't put on Warhammer it's not
law friendly maybe one day that's all
I'm saying no you keep your hobby I'll
keep mine so I think you've briefly
mentioned it earlier in the video but
like just to clarify what what platforms
is this game coming out so far it's been
announced for PC Xbox one and
PlayStation 4 and we've got fingers
crossed with switch but like I said
don't know yet but being the Warhammer
nerd that I am i occupy the unique
position that I get to tell all the
wonderful listeners about all these
Warhammer games so if chaos pain looks
like your cup of tea or you are a warmer
nerd like I am then I mean no brainer I
mean make sure you stay tuned to game
spot